A couple of new adapted monsters from the
original Scary Stories book trilogy have been
revealed in the new trailer, so if you want
to hear about those, then stick around -- to
the end of this video.
But first…
I’ve been waiting all winter to hang this
baby back up.
So the new Scary Stories trailer contains
a mix of new footage and stuff we’ve seen
before in the Super Bowl Teasers.
If you’re sitting there wondering, “why
I haven’t seen that footage; what are you
talking about?” -- it could be because you’re
not subscribed with deathbell notifications
on?
So the trailer starts, as many movie trailers
do, establishing the setting.
1960s.
Mill Valley, Pennsylvania.
Our characters discover a spooky house and
go inside where we see our first Thing You
Missed.
Yeah, we got a counter now, because I ran
a poll and you guys said yeah… might as
well put a counter.
The room is lit by candle light -- and this
whole situation is probably a reference to
The Curse, a story from More Scary Stories
To Tell In The Dark, in which some college
kids are doing a frat initiation where they
must explore this deserted house with a candle.
The other students watch from outside where
they see that each pledge who attempts the
dare disappears after their candle goes out
on the third floor.
Eventually, they all go up to investigate,
thinking it was some kind of prank, but they
find nothing, with no sign of the disappeared
students.
Every year since then, a frat member has died
or gone crazy, and the writer of the story
is the only one left remaining.
My guess is that this college initiation was
changed to a high school dare to better fit
the characters of this movie.
The kids in the movie find this book, and
it seems that the scary stories from the book
start to come true and haunt their town.
I’m guessing this is one of the illustrations
found in that book.
Not quite as creepy as some of the illustrations
in the actual book trilogy that this movie
is based on, but still kind of creepy to find
an old picture containing a headless sailor
just standing there.
It looks like they are going to be combining
tales from different stories.
Headlessness is one of the most common themes
found in the books, as someone loses their
head, literally in six different short stories:
“May I Carry Your Basket”, “Aaron Kelley’s
Bones”, “Oh Susanna”, “The Brown Suit”,
“It’s Him” and the iconic “Me Tie
Doughty Walker”.
But the sailor outfit can only point to one
story called “Somebody Fell From Aloft”,
about a mysterious body that falls onto a
ship on an oversea voyage.
If you pause on the next image you’ll see
that “May I Carry Your Basket” and “Somebody
Fell From Aloft” are next to each other
in the movie version of the book, despite
the fact that they aren’t even in the same
book in real life.
There’s one short story that’s generally
regarded the highest by fans, and that is
“Harold”, the tale of two farmers who
make a scarecrow and name it after another
farmer, Harold, that they don’t like.
The Scarecrow becomes a punching bag for them
whenever they needed to let off some steam,
but eventually start to notice that Harold
is making grunting noises, growing, and eventually
walking around on their roof and deskinning
his victims.
The trailer shows the ominous cornfield, Harold
possibly watching one of the farmers and Harold’s
angry expression as his face crawls with cockroaches
-- this looks like it’s going to be even
creepier than the story that it’s based
on.
Another story I think we’ll see is called
“The Bed By The Window”.
In the trailer, we see the kids approaching
this hospital, and in the story, patients
who have the bed next to the window keep dying.
One man who moves into the bed keeps describing
how amazing the window view is -- so this
other guy named George ends up murdering him
in his sleep so that he can move into the
bed with the window view, but when he gets
there, all he can see is a brick wall.
Since the movie is going to be combining stories,
I think the hallway scene where we see the
Pale Skinned Lady from “The Dream” could
be at that same hospital -- I believe in the
last video I speculated that it might have
been their high school.
By the way, if you want to hear my analysis
of The Pale Skinned Lady, The Big Toe Creature,
The Red Spot or The Gangly Boi, I go more
in depth about those in my Scary Stories Teaser
Analysis video, which you can check out here.
The trailer also features a police officer
character, which is probably a smart choice
considering that there are at least five stories
in the books where cops get involved.
There’s “High Beams”, in which they
arrest a man found hiding in the back of a
girl’s truck with a knife; “The Babysitter”,
in which they arrest an intruder hiding in
an attic; “The Viper” in which a paranoid
man alerts the police of some suspicious phone
calls but it turns out to be a German janitor
who vants to vipe his vindows…
...by the looks of things I could use a Viper
right about now myself…
... then there’s “The Window”, not to
be confused by the previously mentioned “The
Bed By The Window”, where police are called
after a vampire breaks into someone’s house
through the window even though that’s not
allowed with vampires; and finally, “The
Trouble”.
This one has the most police involvement -- it’s
about a house that is seemingly possessed
by a Poltergeist and the stubborn detective
tries his best to find a rational explanation
for everything that's happened.
This cop’s jailhouse looks to play a significant
role as the home of the monster from “The
Thing.”
The characters in that story describe a strange
creature crawling out of a turnip field.
At first it looks like some kind of weird
animal, but then they realize it is vaguely
human.
This might be the creepiest image in the trailer
actually if you slow it down and get a good
look at this The Thing’s face.
I’m sure there will probably be some weirdo
in the comments though who thinks he’s cute...
“Who’s a good boy?”
There’s one more new creature at the very
end of the trailer.
Now there are several ghosts throughout the
series, but I think this is the ghost from
“The Haunted House”, a story from the
first book.
It’s about a preacher who tries to put an
uneasy spirit to rest.
He hears murderous sounds within the house,
before the ghost eventually approaches him
and tells the story of how her lover killed
her for her money and hid her body in the
cellar.
She wants him to give her a proper burial
and use her detached finger to find the her
killer.
He puts the finger in the collection plate
at church, and it sticks to the man who murdered
her.
He confesses to his crimes, and so the ghost
tells the preacher where to find the hidden
money.
But the spot where the ghost initially grabbed
his coat has her finger marks permanently
burned into the cloth.
I’m going to keep you up to date on any
things you might have missed in future teasers
and trailers for Scary Stories to Tell In
The Dark.
By the way, how many was that?.
Ohh okay, so that’s how many there were.
No more comments questioning the number of
Things You Missed.
That just leaves the comments saying “you
don’t know what I missed -- how dare you
assume what I missed.”
If you haven’t seen the video on the left,
watch that to see about the other creatures
that I didn’t cover in this video, and remember
to subscribe to CZsWorld for new horrors every
week -- ring that deathbell for notifications,
and I’ll see you in the next episode, assuming
we both survive.